y quiero que se imaginen a una niña a la
que le encanta aprender y leer novelas
de ficción es su actividad ahorita
en 1998 ella y su familia emigraron
desde colombia hacia los eeuu
encontrando muchas diferencias entre los
dos países
idioma cultura procesos y por esto esta
niña siente la necesidad de ayudar a sus
padres a navegar el sistema educativo
traduciendo cartas que reciben en casa
accediendo a recursos solicitando el
ingreso a la universidad y buscando
becas y en hacer esto por varios años
ella aprende la mejor forma de estudiar
cómo acceder y acceder a recursos y
cuáles herramientas ella necesitaba para
ser exitosa muchos jóvenes como esta
niña ya son hasta asumir el rol de
facilitadores de su propia enseñanza
muchos de ellos ya son expertos en su
propio aprendizaje
sin embargo cuando creamos experiencias
educativas tendemos a basarnos más en
los profesores los educadores los padres
ponemos a los adultos en la ecuación
dejamos a los jóvenes por fuera
en esta idea se basó el enfoque que tomo
mi equipo durante esta pandemia
yo trabajo enroscar software centro
fuera todo el año facilitamos una
experiencia de líder de liderazgo para
niñas en poblaciones vulnerables niñas
de 6 a 15 años de minorías étnicas y
raciales y de bajos recursos económicos
en nuestra área sabemos que muchas de
las familias no tienen acceso a un
computador si usan un computador es a
través de la biblioteca y obviamente eso
no era una opción durante esta pandemia
es fácil frustrar los si pensamos en
cómo puedo crear contenido educativo si
estas familias no tienen esas
herramientas pero en vez de pensar en
eso escogimos averiguar cuáles
herramientas estas familias si tenían y
usarlas sabemos que muchos muchas de las
niñas y los padres en nuestra región
tienen smartphone con acceso a redes
sociales sabíamos que necesitábamos
actividades fáciles y que necesitamos
actividades que no requerían muchos
materiales
cuando cuando creamos experiencias
educativas en que nos basamos para
escoger los temas y los medios que
usamos
pensamos en si la actividad es divertida
o si los jóvenes tienen la oportunidad
de interpretar esa actividad con su
propia propia creatividad
eso sería lo ideal pero en realidad lo
que hacemos es que basamos las
actividades en los los resultados
esperados por nuestras organizaciones o
estándares estatales que son muy
importantes porque nos ayudan a medir el
impacto que estamos teniendo en los
jóvenes y en la comunidad y ver si
estamos marcando una diferencia pero en
hacer eso muchas veces perdemos el
interés de los jóvenes los estudiantes
deben ser el centro de la creación de
contenido educativo
el objetivo debe ser crear experiencias
con ellos usando herramientas que sean
accesibles y cercanas a los jóvenes que
están estamos intentando servir
estudios muestran que cuando los
estudiantes hacen una parte y participan
activamente en el proceso de aprendizaje
hay más motivación la experiencia en la
escuela es mejor hay un mayor y mejores
de las relaciones entre el maestro y
estudiante y hay mayor sentido de
identidad en los estudiantes cuando nos
enfrentamos a esta pandemia queríamos
usar una de las plataformas de vídeo de
redes sociales estamos pensando en
youtube o 'tik tok' estas son
herramientas que las niñas ya estaban
utilizando para expresarse y que se
pueden acceder desde un teléfono yo sé
que las niñas usan tick tock con
frecuencia
este es un vídeo de algunas de los niños
de mi tropa completando un desafío de un
baile baile viral en tick tock que sería
cierto
pero el único inconveniente es que
querían firmar sus desafíos de baile
durante mi clase
me di cuenta que me iban a prestar más
atención si les prometía dejar de filmar
sus vídeos al final de la sesión y
ayudado también que yo me uniera a los
vídeos
tito es una red social donde puedes ver
vídeos de cortos de entre 10 y 60
segundos es popular porque todos los
días hay algo diferente que puedes hacer
chistes hay tendencias bill virales hay
bailes
víctor tiene 800 millones de usuarios
activos por todo el mundo y esos esos
usuarios pasan 52 minutos al día de
promedio en esa aplicación la aplicación
fomenta la creatividad porque tiene
efectos y música que puedes usar para
personalizar los vídeos y sabemos que
las niñas ya están utilizando esta
aplicación
entonces fue eso fue esto que nos hizo
considerarla una plataforma útil para
crear y siempre para crear nuestro
contenido educativo y para motivar a las
niñas a compartir sus ideas y proyectos
es importante recalcar que las niñas ya
estaban utilizando esta aplicación no es
algo nuevo que tenían que aprender a
usar como algunos de los de los de las
plataformas que están usando las
escuelas durante esta pandemia
a mediados de marzo los centros
comunitarios y las escuelas anunciaron
que no regresarían de sus vacaciones de
primavera sabíamos que los niños
necesitaban nuestras actividades de
nuestro programa más que nunca y que
necesitábamos actuar rápidamente en 10
días nuestro equipo publicó una página
web de actividades que las niñas podían
hacer desde la casa y publicamos nuestro
primer vídeo en tick tock
desde ese primer día hemos abordado una
serie de temas como naturaleza arte
bienestar ciencia tecnología ingeniería
a nuestros vídeos éstos han
estructurados con la meta de inspirar a
nuestro público los bombeos no son
vídeos que las niñas simplemente vean
pero que se sientan inspiradas a salir y
hacer ese proyecto solas o con su
familia
uno de mis temas favoritos es la de la
naturaleza hicimos un proyecto que se
llama una aventura en un círculo con una
cuerda en mi ejemplo yo usé un par de
audífonos salía al aire libre busquen un
espacio marque un círculo en la tierra y
me senté a observar el pequeño
ecosistema el vídeo de ese proyecto
recibió 824 visiten visitantes y 55
likes hicimos otro proyecto de un
autorretrato hecho con naturaleza aquí
les muestro algunas de las fotos
hemos utilizado otras formas de contacto
y comunicación con las familias durante
esta pandemia todos los días leemos
cuentos en facebook live mandamos
mensajes de texto o correos electrónicos
a todos los padres de las niñas
registradas en nuestro programa para
contarles del contenido que estamos
publicando y también hemos dejado en
paquetes de materiales en los centros de
distribución en nuestra región para
compartirlas
durante este proceso hemos identificado
varias limitaciones de la aplicación de
tics ok debido a que los vídeos de
nosotros son públicos no estamos seguros
si la gente que está interactuando con
nosotros en la aplicación son niñas
registradas en nuestro programa o acaso
si son gente que viven en nuestra región
pueden estar en cualquier parte del
mundo la seguridad también es otro tema
importante de conversación algunos
padres le tienen miedo a esta aplicación
por el contenido que algunos usuarios
crean
han habido críticas de el contenido que
han publicado imágenes inapropiados
publicados en esta en esta aplicación
pero también hemos aprendido mucho
durante durante este proceso el
algoritmo que utiliza tipo que es muy
preciso y en identificar nuestra
audiencia basándonos en los las fotos de
perfil y el contenido de las cuentas que
nos siguen estimamos que nos nuestros
seguidores son niñas entre los 8 y 14
años
poco a poco estamos aprendiendo que hace
que un vídeo sea popular y como podamos
crear el contenido de mejor calidad
ganamos seguidores a diario desde ese
primer día hemos publicado 37 vídeos y
nuestro hashtag que estamos usando tiene
más de 23 mil visitas
recibimos comentarios positivos de la
comunidad de nuestros socios y de
nuestros patrocinadores y el contenido
que creamos va a seguir siendo útil en
casos y desconstruir des continuamos el
uso de esta plataforma después de la
pandemia
los documentos ideas y actividades que
tenemos los podemos usar en el futuro
esa niña que emigró de desde colombia a
los estados unidos que aprendió cómo
acceder a recursos como cuál es la mejor
forma de estudiar y cómo ser exitosa y
cuáles herramientas necesitaba esa niña
fui yo
entonces me pregunto en este tiempo de
estancia miento social en qué
actividades me gustaría participar a mí
si yo fuera a cargo de mi propio
aprendizaje
espero que los adultos a cargo de crear
esas actividades pensaran en mí en mis
gustos y en mis necesidades
eso todo me hace reflexionar si todas
las reglas sobre la creación de
contenido educativo todos los procesos
de revisión interna funcionan siempre a
nuestro favor o son barreras para
nuestra propia innovación y crear una
barrera para que los jóvenes participen
en el proceso y creen con nosotros
espero que cuando esta cuando esta
pandemia termine y nosotros nos podamos
ver otra vez las cosas no vuelvan
exactamente a la normalidad
estaremos aún más en sintonía con las
cosas que les gustan a los jóvenes lo
que les parece divertido porque hemos
aprendido mucho sobre las cosas que
están haciendo y creando en plataformas
como tic toc
tal vez esto nos haya abierto los ojos a
las oportunidades ilimitadas para con
crear experiencias con jóvenes con los
estudiantes en el centro de todo
muchas gracias
[Música]